olha ai olá pessoal então tá tudo ficou
o lado pessoal do que quem fala é o dark
sejam muito bem vindos a mais um ele e
os estragos de que este cofre só olha lá
ó é muito grande diz o que você já sabe
é que vou fazer o pessoal hoje eu vou
tentar reabrir este copo sem chapa
não conheço nada e não só como vocês
puderam ver nunca enviou ontem que o
cofre é muito fácil mesmo e isso é que
vai dar muito mais trabalho portanto
peço o vosso e meia é que neste vídeo e
se inscrevam se ainda não foi inscrito
só tem uma dúvida não sei se vocês
repararam mas já cheguei aos 3 milhões
de escravos
o trabalho oficina eu não vou fazer
somos muito obrigado mesmo eo pronto
pronto quando a escassos três milhões de
inscritos eu ia fazer o comentário
namorada dois mas vamos lançar outra
metade que se eu conseguir 100 mil
comentários e poderão como evitar a
namorada de 2 200 duzentos mil salvar
200 mil comentários com este teve como
evitar a namorada dois eu trago mais
rápido possível mesmo possua este é o
cofre do blindado muito blindada olhe
aqui é muito duro e que é muito o veneno
mec
este é o ponto fraco atrás para trazer o
ponto fraco
já está aberto - entendo xuxa pessoal
vamos devolver o golpe só vamos mover o
cofre paulo borges tratamento só vamos
lá então tentar abrir os cofres e xavi
mas primeiro vamos mostrar o que tem
aqui dentro só para isso é que do lado
tem um painel isso para ela não vou usar
porque preciso de pilha e eu não tenho e
nem vejam só vou usar que chávez nem a
biota tão potente é tão lindo que nem
água
aí eu sei lá o unisul e suporta mas não
sou grosso da porta do sol a lei é muito
grossa clientes até tem um tom secreto
olha só para isso tão secreto só pegar
aqui neste botão tudo mundo pode ser
olha aí para só
i will to fazendo aqui dentro diz fran
em outro cofre além do grande coxipó
vinho muito blindada escova cai pessoal
tá na hora de trancar isso tudo vamos
trancar tudo contato trancado e eu vou
mandar estes dos sábios platina uma duas
e eu nem vou usar essa eu vou tentar
abrir os cofres só com as minhas
ferramentas martelo um motel mas porque
no machadão este que foi conseguiu abrir
o cofre anterior é muito potente mostrar
mas eu comprei uma ferramenta ainda mais
potente do que isso uma chapa
esta ferramenta que igual
eu acho que é mais importante um bom não
é
olha só vence em abril não descobri que
eu comprei uma super picareta olha só eu
mas o tráfego aéreo só eu acho que isso
vai aumentar o cofre muito fácil olha só
exibe muito bicudo olha eu vou tentar
furar até 321 vai até aqui com pouca
força imaginei isso dentro do cofre e
vai abrir um buraco muito grande mas
para votar mas tem que ser com muita
força e claro que só ela também usar as
nossas bombinhas eu acho que não vai dar
em nada mas é sempre bom experimentar a
estrada muito muito barulho
acho que cheguei a 1 em cima do painel e
outra que perdeu shopping de mecanismos
inteligentes que eu sou gay mas quero
estar pronto e vou recorrer não vai ter
que ficar aqui pedrão mas novela ainda
mais dólares 124 passo atrás dos 5 3 2 1
[Risadas]
não fiz nada igual
eu acho que consegui arrancar este
painel circuito
vou usar uma tela agora sexta feira
o brasil hoje é quarta feira na ilha da
sicília ele só hoje vamos manter com a
sexta feira embora 31 bairro morro
jabril juro olha aqui olha que já entrou
por dentro portanto vamos marcar mas que
só agora ó cansa muito e não faz nada o
corpo está intacto mas entrou mais por
dentro da lei
olha essa faixa aí ok pessoal vou
aproveitar agora que este buraco e
voltar o pé de cabra é a cidade agora 31
bairro guanady bem duro não mas quase
não é muito duro é muito resistente
não faço nada eu falei falei lei abre
mesmo não tá pra ele mesmo lançou agora
é só puxar para cima a cuidar da ilha
mas o pessoal está brincando você estar
aqui em cima do guarda-roupa solo já
sabem não tem em casa nem usem estas
técnicas para abrir o cofre o vosso país
só sabem deixei muito laquê neste vídeo
porque eu consegui abrir os cofres
buscar um ainda mais segura e potente a
não dá a sensação que é fácil de abrir
mas tem que uma figura gigante
inexplorado aqui há só eu acho que na
altura do céu machado ainda não o
picareta é uma chata deus porque a
unidade começar muita habilidade pessoal
132 vai
vejam suas marcas por aí marca da lâmina
marca de lâminas marca da lâmina e não
acontece nada e não há muito não ao vivo
vamos ver agora qual foi o contrário
vamos tentar outra vez machado
esta é a parte mais mal agora é que
entra mesmo agora vai entrar o 321 vai
ficar mesmo pessoal que eu já vim
preparado já vem preparado e sabe como
charles não ia dar não vai funcionar e
foi por isso que o autor comprei ama
preta esta vai funcionar eu tinha
certeza que o a 32 o picareta contra
cofre
boró eu sabia que funcionar um buraco
tem um buraco que colocar vamos
continuar a tentar tudo
[Música]
a lei é muito buraco assim nosso ver não
acredito aí posso ver eu vou abrir o
cofre chuva ainda mais difícil a um ato
muito cansado muito trabalho nem todos
vós mega agora vamos mostrar o nosso
poder aqui procópio embora quanto mais
leve mais força à equipe grega 321 vai
abrir os cofres
eu tenho de abrir o cofre não sai daqui
sempre o cofre
o
mas a bola bateu o olé brasil vai agora
agora vai agora aguardar a etapa
portuguesa que vem aí o que está por
trás da política
meu deus eu vou conseguir voltar vivo
[Música]
o cdc dá assim a itajaí vai sair eu acho
acho que já está aberto não à porta
fechada
o governo está aberto a porta tiveram
medo eu vou ficar aqui muito tempo
ae
olha isso
agora fui tempo frio
olha esse velho tuma morreu estou muito
cansado mas conseguimos que quiserem ver
como enfrentar a namorada dois sabem
comentem este é como estar a namorada 2
200 mil comentários e já sabendo só nós
conseguimos abrir os cofres para a
próxima vou buscar com mais segurança e
espero que tenham gostado já sabem
companhias dos vídeos que também serão
aqui no canal se inscrever aqui embaixo
ei fiquem bem e até a próxima